my very first food memory was when i was
three or four
it was a warm day and my mom had just
picked me and my sister up from school
buckled us into the back of her dusty
blue ford taurus
she was halfway out of the school
parking lot when she pulled over to the
side
she strangely reached for her purse that
was resting on the dashboard started
fishing around for something until she
found it
then she twisted around to us and she
tore open
a yellow paper bag of slightly melted
sugar babies
she poured a few of the pellets into
each of our tiny hands
now i want to be clear this was not a
normal mom thing this was breaking
several rules
it was after lunch but before dinner
we were in the car
we hadn't done anything spectacular to
be celebrated and sugar babies are well
pure sugar
i was so confused
but i was a kid so i took the candy and
i started chewing
i felt like i had just been inducted
into the coolest club possible
the one that eats candy on a random
wednesday
and then
the world it slowed down
everything faded
and then everything sharpened
there's only one word for what i felt in
that moment
magic
real
magic
now most
people think that that's kind of crazy
three or four years old i don't remember
anything about my childhood for years
after that but i remember that day
i remember those sugar babies
and i remember that feeling
now most people think of magic
as a trick
right abracadabra
this
seemingly impossible act put on purely
for entertainment
but i'd like to challenge that
magic
real magic
is not an illusion
real magic is the feeling
when life transformed from the ordinary
into the extraordinary
and not only is it real
it is the very thing that connects us to
this world
to one another
to our entire existence
it's the spark of a moment
it's the feeling of believing
of belonging
of getting
of being gotten
it is the crack
that opens up our hearts and remem
reminds us to let light in
now
i own milk bar this quirky american
style bakery that i'll tell you a little
bit about later
and i have found
that magic is often created by breaking
some sort of rule
like the no sweets before dinner rule
or
wearing overalls to a corporate board
meeting
or simply daring to defy the
expectations of the people around us
now as a kid breaking the rules usually
only got us in trouble right
but as adults
it's a different story
breaking the rules pushing boundaries
challenging the norm
asking why why not it does something to
us
it shakes us from sleepwalking
and it makes space
for magic to sneak in
now i was raised by matriarchs fierce
heroic grandmas who loved to bake in
their free time
and they knew good and well that food
was for nutrition and sustenance
but they didn't care
baked
as their way of breaking the rules
they'd make batches of lemon bars
instead of casseroles
or one pot wonders and they put those
baked goods in baggies and hand them out
hand that magic out to the most
unassuming people the newcomer
to the neighborhood the mail carrier or
my personal favorite the receptionist at
the dentist office
[Laughter]
now
i knew what the receiving end of magic
felt like from that sugar baby moment
but witnessing
what the giving part of real magic
did
it moved these people
it was awe-inspiring
and so i decided
that baking would be my way of making
magic in the world
creating a moment and then giving it
away
a magic pyramid scheme basically that i
wanted needed more of
only
my mom and my grandmas thought that
baking was just a hobby
but i knew it could be more than that
i moved to new york city to become a
professional pastry chef
i went to culinary school i climbed the
ladder of fancy restaurants making fancy
desserts to become the very best of the
best
only
i never found magic in those beautiful
delicate plated desserts
i could only find my magic
in a cookie
or a slice of cake
or gooey under-baked pie
and so when i opened milk bar that
bakery that i was telling you about
i decided
i wasn't gonna frost the sides
of the cake like the textbooks taught me
i decided i was gonna load cookie dough
with marshmallows
or pretzels and potato chips and
butterscotch chips and coffee tossing
convention out the window
i wanted people to eat birthday cake not
just on their birthday but any day they
wanted
i knew that my magic
came in the form of these simple baked
goods
but i also knew
that simple approachable accessible
nostalgic flavors
were my best jumping off place to create
new desserts
almost as though fancy were the enemy of
delicious
i'd go to county fairs to nosh
i'd go to the diner and order slices of
pie from that revolving display case
i'd take french fries and dip them in
chocolate milkshake
and dream
and then i'd go into the kitchen and tie
on my apron
and start mixing up
a new creation
rooted in something known and safe and
loved
but reaching far beyond what anyone
thought accessible
or approachable
or doable
breaking the baking rules became my
daily ritual
i mean who says a layer cake can't taste
like salty multi-sweet pretzels
i mean my culinary instructors for one
watch me i'd think and i'd take pretzels
toast them in the oven to deepen their
flavor then grind them into a powder
like consistency
and substitute some of the cake flour in
a recipe for that pretzel powder
it's pretty good
when i was opening milk bar i knew i
wanted to serve ice cream
a rebellious kind of ice cream no
surprise right
so i decided to buy a soft serve machine
which for the record was very rebellious
at the time
had to decide what flavor to make
i mean why do we only accept chocolate
and vanilla
as ice cream flavors
i needed to come up with something
better different
push that boundary
i needed to come up with a flavor of
milk
that was different milk is like the base
of any great ice cream
so i sought out inspiration
at my 24-hour bodega favorite place to
go
because that's where we all shop that's
where our simple taste buds are formed
it's the flavors we know
up and down the aisles
till i hit it
my favorite section of the grocery store
as a kid
the cereal aisle
now as a kid my mom and i had an
agreement it was a pretty picky eater
and we agreed that i
could have as much cereal as i wanted as
long as i drank all the calcium rich
milk at the bottom of the bowl
i mean i thought it was highway robbery
does she not understand how good that
sugary sweet milk was at the bottom
that's interesting
that's a really delicious flavor of milk
it moved me
it made sense to me
but would it make sense to other people
i figured i'd give it a try
so i went back to the kitchen and made
the equivalent of a giant bowl of cereal
i strained out all that delicious milk
and i spun it into ice cream
put it on the menu
and i got to tell you even now people
stop me on the street to tell me about
their cereal milk ice cream moment
so good seemingly a little naughty i
mean how did i know that was their
flavor that's the flavor they eat when
they're wearing pajamas when no one's
looking the flavor of their childhood
these people will tell me about
every detail of the day they will tell
me about the weather the company they
kept
the way that an ordinary moment was
transformed into something magical with
a simple bite
i built my business with the same
challenge the norm mentality
rather than measure my business success
by the profit or loss sheet by the
average order value the other metrics
that businesses use to know if they're
doing well
i decided we'd measure
our impact by the twinkle in people's
eyes
by the oh i can't put that down feeling
that they had when they ate one of our
desserts
i chose to put women at the helm of my
organization
because when i looked around the
hospitality industry people running
operations folks holding ceo titles
they were all men
i mean why
i was raised by these fierce matriarchs
who handled business
and i wanted my organization to look
like that i wanted to show the world
what women were capable of and what a
bakery could be
push back on that cute little box people
like to put us in
and in turn the rules broke for us
the magic our magic
got
out
word spread without spending a dollar on
marketing
rare in our industry we grew our
business without diluting the business
i mean we want awards no tiny east
village bakery has any business winning
it's pretty incredible
even today
i get to witness
that feeling that same one that my
grandma's conjured up in my childhood
we ship cakes all across the country we
keep our doors open from early in the
morning until late at night it's insane
for a bakery to do
but we do it because we're obsessed with
it we're obsessed with what we do
we teach classes we share recipes
despite any concerns of copycats or
intellectual property infringements
because
that's what you do when you benefit from
what came before you
and you plan on passing it along long
after you
when thank you
when you know you're here to give not
take
and leave this place better than you
found it
see mom
you can't bake for a living pretty cool
if you ask me
now i don't have the full equation
correct
but i do know that it starts with a
decision to act
my mom she could have drove that car
home routinely
but she decided that that day would not
be like the others
she threw out that rule book for just a
second
i carry this lesson with me that every
day has within it hundreds
thousands of opportunities
to create real magic
only they disappear
unless you reach out and grab them
thank you